mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos team fi verbindung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der in bombay street live am zürichsee
eine beschauliche szenerie und
überschaubar
vor der pandemie sei es bei gewissen
festivals
doch auch dieses jahr mussten viele open
erst wieder absagen ein paar finden
statt in kleinerem rahmen mit knappen
budget mit den bands wurde verhandelt
damit verspiele auf die bühne aber die
eine kleine formation also und die
beiden endlich sofort damit
einverstanden sind
party unter freiem himmel geht und in
clubs im herbst
dieser passung america spiel
live konzerte in zeiten von corona ein
wechselbad der gefühle
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz wir legen
heute in lachen an und nehmen sie mit
zum open-air-konzert der schweizer band
77 bombay street ja innovation sogar
leise euphorie macht sich breit nachdem
corona katzenjammer aber auch die angst
vor dem herbst dann wenn open air nicht
mehr geht wir neben der konzert branche
impuls
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt auch kurz vorm letzte
konzert vor der saison highlights
zürichsee sessions hydraulik 77 bombay
street art buch ist schon vorbereitet
hallo wo sie in die regierung kommen wir
später wenn es dann kurz vorm auftritt
so richtig los geht's auf dem wir die
harte arbeit machen und die andere kann
man auch herr gorny genau also wieder
hinunter so kursiert dass ich eigentlich
immer noch auf und schon mit dem krug
mit gomez hofstelle dollar sie richtet
brauche bevor die band weiß wohl dass
zara gehört und so und das ist jetzt
darf er wieder spielen will ich das
überhaupt ja es ist megaschön und mega
wichtig für uns wir sind live band und
wenn mir nicht live das feedback
bekommen von der luxe klappmesser das
motivationsspritze denn ist das weniger
zum proben und trat lieben unser
land profitiere auch von deiner
absaugung russland das werden wir auf
den schweizer bei und setzt braucht kann
sie aber nicht alles muss lang
profitieren die vereine verlegt wo man
das meer profitiert und ist kumpel wo
man zu 210 ko-spiele muslime aber sonst
merkt man das nicht dass man jetzt
würden im video slots von den
ausländischen beanspruchen
[Musik]
die situation mit dem schaeffler-konzern
jahr soll speziell habe nicht jeder
wir sind ja parierte start unserer
familie
ja es ist ja wirklich viel populärer
gemacht worden sind da ist im urteil
stehen womit er einen altersheim und
spittal und so sind frauen zwischen 18
und dann ist natürlich wirklich mit den
eltern mit behinderten und sodann ist
viel parallele gemacht
aber mittlerweile ist immer noch zu
viert und
[Musik]
das sind neu die haben mein letzter
gemacht also mehr heißt zusammen
entworfen mit unserem motto was noch
umgesetzt hat genau das ist ja
tatsächlich eine totale familienbetrieb
bis auf toni formates oft kostüm sonntag
wieso eigentlich in form das ist echt
komische geschichte der hand wo man die
erste single user gar handvoll dieser
millionensumme darüber diskutiert wie
werden wir unser ziel war - und hat
insofern waren die hass säen und denn
ich war toni vor wenn ich mir haben wir
den kunden trikots und das hätten so gut
aussehe dass man in der nächsten zwei
fotoshootings warm gemacht hat mit
anderen ich leider und was immer und aus
hafer und dennoch hat einfach seinen
haben wir solche fluch und segen sind
denn eigentlich mit den uniformen haben
blieb der zweite große pause ich leid
und hand voll durchstarten und dann ist
corona und ich kann mir vorstellen dass
dann auch unglaublich viel absaugen
handvoll konzept für opel sei
ich schätze dass es zwischen zwischen 30
und 40 konzerte gespielt hatte und vor
allem auch ich sage es nun richtig mit
der ganzen band sowie mann hatte weile
spielen aber natürlich das ist darum
sich massiv gebrochen wo man uns
eigentlich erhofft hatte für die letzten
zwei jahren dank
[Musik]
ausgebremst von corona das ist das
schicksal aller die auf der bühne stehen
natürlich auch die organisatoren sind am
kämpfen wieso aber die eine netz
trotzdem erfolge feiern können andere
aber ihre pläne nicht umsetzen konnten
das hat ganz unterschiedliche gründe wir
haben genau hingeschaut was die musik
event branche momentan umtreibt
das traditionelle pop festival gurten in
bern ausgehebelt vom temporären
grossanlass verboten
das hippe zürich openair da
internationale stars heuer kaum touren
[Musik]
nein beim rock stelldichein greenfield
in interlaken war niemand
doch ich ich will doch ich kann nicht
galt auch für st
dafür konnte kürzlich das openair gampel
im kanton wallis über die bühne geht als
eines der ersten überregionalen pop
festivals in der schweiz
die planung komplex war lange unklar
blieb ob wann und unter welchen
bedingungen großevents wieder erlaubt
werden
entsprechend erhöhte sich derzeit druck
auf die verantwortlichen
april wird ende
juni aber noch die bewilligung kreierten
privat eigentlichen das festival ist am
boden stampfen und da wir die
bewilligung und kreative juli
und dann ist endlich normal vor neue
situation stellt war nicht
unproblematisch weil plötzlich wieder
das große fest zu machen aber die werden
gesagt weil er das so durchziehen wie
das geplante tat diese glitzer
überschaubarer frisch vom
sicherheitsaspekt von gesundheitsaspekt
und es jetzt endlich so durchgezogen ich
glaube das richtige wachs die folge
verkleinerte bands wie hier lohnt mit dj
primär aus der schweiz wegen
reisebeschränkungen und bloß ein drittel
der sonst 30.000 besuchenden pro tag
es ist allemal klar dass er nie mit zwei
großen bühnen vor das ist einfach haben
vom bildschirm von der kapazität
gekommen weil der schweizer war zeitlose
die zwischen tagesschau
kammerspielen auf die bühne aber die
müssen wir kleinere formationen und
gemeinsinn endlich sofort einverstanden
sind und ich glaube ich sage das online
petition medistar challenge und das
mitmachen das wird für sie in gampel in
der nächste halt irgendwann ist
[Musik]
kleinere besetzungen tiefere gagen
ausnahme der internationale top-act jan
delay er vollzog den grenzübertritt
mitsamt groß formation
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht aber für
für mich und für uns ist es
erste normale festival dieser art
und dann ist so schön und
deshalb haben wir jetzt hier folgen ist
vorbereitet
[Musik]
nichts ging dagegen ab beim open air in
st gallen weder 2020 noch 20 21 im
festivalgelände natur statt
infrastruktur ein großteil für diesen
teams
emotional kann einfache geschichte und
lieferanten
im moment
hätten die maßnahmen kurzarbeit
wer es gab sehr schwarz für die branche
so hätten sie verhandle das behördliche
verbot brauchte christopher als
juristische grundlage um die planung zu
stoppen und die nächste ausgabe
aufzugleisen
die hat er vergangene woche angekündigt
wir sind natürlich mit ab sagt wieder
gegangen und handfest über 22 20 uhr
hand bestätigung über homers
imparato eigentliche wahnsinn interessen
auto wurde in headliner news bestätigt
hätten
[Musik]
ich stimme auf sich selber jetzt einfach
warten bis es neue steuer und den
abgründen oder soll ich die positive
nachricht weil die motivation sind
glaube für die junge leute wo sich zuvor
jetzt wurde doch bald wie gott wieder
mit dem opener ich glaube mich ein
zeichen setzen und estate mannheim rück
macht ein wichtiges zeichen auch für
schweizer bands alexis amerikaner
begleitet die hiesige szene seit über
einem jahr für einen dokumentarfilm der
sternstunde musik im dezember und kam
mir sehr nahe wenn wir über so lange
zeit
beschränkt wird in dem was man macht
nicht nur beschränkt und zum teil
gestoppt wird dann stellt das natürlich
viel größere frage existenzielle frage
wer bin ich als
kunstschaffende in dem land was
musikschaffende was ist mir lieb
gesellschaftliche bedeutung was ich mit
eigenen wert als wertschöpfende kraft in
dem land und so weiter und so fort dass
es gott den wirklich plötzlich um sehr
viel größere thema raus nur wieviel
garten in bodman er
[Musik]
auftritte ermöglicht das anstehende
heitere openair in zu finden zwar vor
kleiner kulisse als gewohnt dafür mit
weiteren konzerten im vorfeld christoph
bill staffel das angebot seines
festivals profit bedingt mirant square
kaum ist in höchster wermes ganze
konzept skalierbar machen das heißt man
ein können zwischen drei und sagst du
sie glüht eigentlich schon karriere
versus 12 die sich um eine normale ja
das heißt land sieht anders aus hat nur
eine bühne während der zeltplatz weg
glauben ganz andere geschichte haben
müssen passen infrastrukturell gut
angebot aus dem prinzip immer was ganz
neues erfunden
dazu zählt die option das openair
virtuell zu erleben wer wegen der
pandemie lieber zu hause bleibt oder
kein copy zertifikat besitzt kann sich
per livestream zu schalten und mit
besuchenden in kontakt treten
für rund 20 franken pro tag
nichts ersetzt jedoch den realen
festivalbesuch bloß wie 2009 10 wird es
nicht das publikum hält sich zurück es
droht ein minus von mehreren
hunderttausend franken
wir sehen möchte muss ich ganz klar
sagen was der vorverkauf anbelangt mehr
hand natürlich die frau schaute ich sehe
an der fußball-europameisterschaft
bereit überall stehen könnte mir wenn
dies wieder live immer ganz sicher und
selbstverständlich planen oder derartige
jetzt im raum wurde vor der realität wo
jeder pessimistisches szenario
solche bilder wünschen sich die
veranstalter zurück doch die auswahl der
bands ist eingeschränkt das publikum
verunsichert und die organisation trotz
redimensionierung teuer die stimmung
also nicht nur 3
[Musik]
felix keil 120 120 mitorganisiert mit
kreiert was hat ausschlag für die reihe
zu schlagen scheinlich sie das
geschäftsmodell christoph kumpa
zumindest für inneres und seite tv jahn
jetzt bin ich fertig sie in italien
strand und jetzt zurück
ich denke hey wie schön wäre es wenn ich
so eine band spielen und füßen
bürokräfte zu wissen und das bürofenster
gestand und seither mache das so wie sie
ich habe mich vorstoß das erreichte
große big sleep initiiert
logistische aber politische knacknuss
sondern anhand der drei container sind
diese gemeinde zu gast und da gibt es
ganz viel im moment wüsste was mir das
doch machen und wenn corona uhrzeit den
ist es so dass zwei gekürzt worden sind
und man sehr viel support gespürt vor
der gemeinde vor die konten vor den
erwähnten ämter und damit sind mega
happy dass die idee zu diesem projekt
begeistert sie sind jetzt machen der
sogenannte silent kommt setzt also
ständig konzern kürzt nur hoffe ich
nicht vorstellig da der funke springe
managers oskar unter funkel ich am mega
springe also ich habe damals gar nicht
ganz eine vorstelle aber nicht wirklich
an dem konzert mega noch in der musik in
künstler dass ich glaube für künstler
ist folglich will also für jede falsche
ton aber quintessenz ist russ es
funktioniert und es ist es neues
hörerlebnis ich bin gespannt wer noch
rauer
landestrainer maßnahme ein konzert also
wir haben nie wieder weg vom publikum
und der hand dass sein konzern sogar
alle drei maßnahmen ich glaube dass ich
ein teil sein konzept morgen hat wähler
machen dass es gibt maßnahmen musik jene
schutz gründe machen und zu sagen dass
island ist natürlich nicht viel mit
corona zur sonne film dauert auch dass
man acht shows nacheinander machen und
wenn man immer wieder die gemeinde mega
stark beschossen
und blicken wir auf der anderen seeseite
nur die besten der besten
freunde machen und solche sodass bühne
die musiker aber klären emissionen die
sind natürlich nicht risiko ausgesetzt
dann eigentlich finanziell lohnt sich
der aufwand
ist und mit zahlen natürlich bereits mit
dem projekt davids lehrgeld oder was
meint das jetzt noch mal machen würde
wahrscheinlich effizienter beschaffen es
ist nicht das projekt wo man als
veranstalter viel geld verdienen
ich glaube wir machen schon zweimal
durch alle aufgrund und römer und
terrassen putzen und einfach mal unseren
live erlebnis wenn das ist die größte
ansporn nur der fed aber sagen es wird
finanziell deckt dann christen sponsor
und partner also aber es ist natürlich
so
weiterzugehen
hauptkonzert gemacht
das konzept und
die zukunftschancen bühne auf dem see in
der schweiz
zukunft
für dieses jahr ist es heute abend ganz
bestimmt das letzte konzert danach wird
die seebühne fürs erste an land geholt
im gegensatz dazu sticht das basler
festival floss ab heute in den reihen
und auch in zürich in arbon und ins
spiel finden in den kommenden wochen
freiluftkonzerte statt aber was wird der
herbst der konzert branche bringen diese
frage treibt ganz besonders unsere
kultur platz praktikantin um ireen
lakatos denn für sie sind live konzerte
und tanzen ein lebenselixier
ganze und führe in manchen masse das
fühlt sich nur sehr spezieller und armin
rieg und auch immer wieder trug die kurz
eigentlich weiter
ich habe mir zwei lieblingsklubs noch
krupp-team griffin euro vom fc st nach
deiner lange corona durch schräg findet
die erste inhouse konzert stoppt
in großer saal geschäftsleiter in
mariazell
sie erzählt mir weh die folge mögliche
maßnahmen verschärft hatte
was möglich ist mir in sachen
ausprobiert wie zum beispiel streaming
und residenz am rand hand und im
grundsatz tor um das mehrweg merkt hat
mich eindeutig infrastrukturen
gesprochen jetzt habe vor dem griff
eines konzertes andere da sein will die
verschiedenen veranstaltungen auf den
herbst verlegt worden sind der club sei
finanziell stabil dass der zusätzliche
unterstützung von kanton und stadt der
hand dank der jungs entschädigung unter
kurzarbeit
gut können überleben die hand auch schon
bestehen die subvention einmal
wiederholen was als sehr cool für hat
und somit hat es finanziell nicht weiter
ich kann wieder in der basel
club.de konzertsaison
das programm
zum innenhof mit zertifikat natürlich
nicht fehlen ggg ist der wiese
[Musik]
im club s klasse nicht einig
hinter den kulissen brodelt
ich bin
besorgt ob es überlebe von dem verein
geschafft das ist bitter so einfach
nicht richtig sagen haben jetzt die
partner und pflege das sagen jene
methode ist eigentlich wenigstens die
produktionskosten in spielen oben das
mmk spiel unglücklich während der
pandemie dem ruf der sicher von patek
sie der gruppe mitarbeiten die endlos
und staatliche unterstützung sich bis
jetzt nur fürs jahr 2020 zahlt worte es
hat ist crowdfunding ein tropfen auf den
heißen stein wir haben natürlich so viel
wir haben kultur ist vor allem
entschädigungen kriegt bis dezember
vorläufig januar april sie ständig jetzt
demnächst das muss man durch die ganze
gremien noch völlig prüft werden und mir
also keine künstlergagen auszahle im
fazit von november bis dezember vom
letzten jahr obwohl die aktuelle
situation unterschiedlich weil die klubs
mit auf internationale acts größtenteils
verzichtet und vermeide ich die
planungsunsicherheit eine große
herausforderung
was wirklich schönes paar kredite wenn
die krone ansteckungszahlen gestiegen
für die war
sofort tot
überhaupt ich würde keine partys und
stellt uns sorgen machen fertig sitz
konzertgenuss labour kinderlosen sport
aktuell ist mit konzert in der herbst
rechnen aber wer weiß am besten jeden
moment auskosten und vortrag niesen ich
freue mich wahnsinnig zu rufen wieder
blut wird im griff wenn die luft wieder
da sind wenn es wieder belegt ist die
alte fabrik wird im mit mancher gefehlt
wir wieder an jack hat am nachmittag ein
konzert oder
was auch immer die nächste woche bringe
werde ich weiß jetzt egal wie stark die
vier teile sie wird veranstalterinnen
und veranstalter sind innovativ und
kreativ und ich bin offen für alles was
rund
[Musik]
jetzt sind da alle hier ihre ob ein buch
auf ein sofa liegen der bafin de gibt ja
so ein jammer freuen ist extrem könne
man wieder spieler jetzt schon mal dass
sie längeres als duett unterwegs was so
außer kultisch ab jetzt haben wir zwar
wieder zum zug
es ist cool aussehen man hätte die natur
drückt und die show
haben wir von frau story also in jeder
ton ist ganz genau so normal wie immer
live konzept da kann man sich an aromen
und extrakte werden geht das hat wiens
nervosität
definitiv ja wir leben glücklose
eigentlich genau zu wenn du meine
konzerte zu halten heisst ist
automatisch ein
ganzes volumen und die zahl wir mit dem
kopf zwischen verstimmen studio und das
macht sollte einem schwere grippe man
hat doch schon lange gesagt routine
haben oder lange pause und jetzt wieder
so auf die spiele schon speziell es ist
ja lange durststrecke in ruhe hin rollen
auf der bühne stand was hat corona ich
mach mit europa gemacht ihre zwölf
monate bin ich quasi arbeitslos
klimatologe wiederholen also ich ganz
verrücktes jahr ungefähr und umso größer
ist freut gut wieder alles los und
hoffentlich
das ist ein weiter so
kann es nicht braucht
so wünscht eine gute nacht das wird sich
ja mal ihn ist eine junge sängerin mit
wahnsinnsstimme das beweist sie aktuell
auch bei uns bei sf kultur auf instagram
wir haben sie letzte woche bei einem
ihrer auftritte besucht und zwar
zusammen mit der zehnjährigen lila ein
großer fan von teuer
aber ich bin natürlich
und die für ihren
100 emotionen
[Musik]
wechselt
es ist kurz vor dem auftritt in einem
kleinen lokal direkt am zürichsee
[Musik]
die 18 jährige schülerin stimmt sich auf
ihr konzert
[Musik]
eine band gründen
für mich recht klar
dass sie das musik ich bin weg und ihren
klang immer klappt verkauft hat habe
immer wenn sie möglichkeit gehe zum
fortschritt eines der
modernsten und jetzt das mit
erfolg
[Musik]
und nicht ganz
es ist bizarr wovon woche mit denn die
melodie die melodie
klappt also durchaus noch eine
inspiration stimmt oder auch ganz
spontan
[Musik]
doch positiv immer noch leben die
bilder
sondern erfüllen sind sie nicht
sympathisch also so wie sie redet
[Applaus]
ja das junge ausnahmetalent mit
wuchtiger reifer stimme und
unverkennbaren songs dürfte noch großes
vorhaben
[Musik]
letzte traum verfolgen so weit wie
möglich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
breaking news
nach hause
[Musik]
aus
hier frei und 77 bombay street dance
sehr kühlen sommerabend hier tauchen
nachher gleich nochmal ein ins konzert
nächste woche da sprechen wir über ehe
für alle über liebe glück und
scheidungsraten und gleich jetzt darauf
die sternstunde philosophie kommen sie
gut durch die woche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
des wissens
[Applaus]